welcome everybody I'm come on I meant on
the economics editor of the BBC and net
it let it never be said that economics
is not the new rock stars because we
have three people here who have filled
out this large auditorium to discuss the
small issue of the state of capitalism
no less ten years on from the financial
crisis now I became business editor of
The Telegraph in 2009 and I remember
meeting Bob Diamond the chief executive
of Barclays Bank big cheer for Barclays
and he asked me a year later when I
thought all this would be over and I
drew myself up to my full height I
thought well Bob I've been a couple more
years of this rather miserable economic
news and I'm sure will be back to you
know proper strong growth and here we
are ludicrous economic forecasts as ever
by me which was totally wrong and we're
still here a ten years later dealing
frankly with the funk of the financial
crisis now of course there have been
some big trends for 2018 which look a
little bit more positive and probably
net positive at the moment we've had
synchronised growth in the main drivers
of the global economy for the first time
since the financial crisis but also
against that quite interestingly we've
had synchronised monetary tightening
very gentle still in a weird world where
we have monetary policies set for a
recession and global growth now
predicted to be close on four percent
how long can that last for in the UK as
we have had across many developed
economies we have this historic income
squeeze there have only been three
general elections since the Second World
War where voters have gone to the
polling booths in Britain suffering and
income squeeze and they are nineteen
forty five 2010
and 2017 that shows the great historic
nature of what we have experienced this
long income squeeze each of those
elections didn't work out that well for
the incumbent Winston Churchill who'd
won a war lost Gordon Brown who had
saved the globe here told us lost
Theresa May almost lost in 2017 so that
shows the fundamentals when you ask
people whether they want change or more
of the same in the present situation
they're gonna go for change whether it's
Donald Trump
whether it's brexit whether it's Jeremy
Corbyn someone who can offer a solution
to where we are is the the person or the
issue that tends to have success we've
had 10 years where returns to capital
have outweighed returns to labor
it was Lord Adair Turner the former head
of the financial services authority who
said to me that capitalism over the last
decade had fundamentally failed in its
central promise to the public that each
year if you work harder and played by
the rules you'd be a little more wealthy
that has not been true for the past
decade the last four quarters of data on
borrowing and saving households have
become net borrowers for the first time
in the data set in the UK which goes
back to the early 1990s we are borrowing
income that we need to keep our
lifestyle at a certain level these are
fundamental issues how much of it is
connected with the financial crisis so I
am joined by three people of such
Planetary brainpower it's going to be
difficult keeping them sort of on topic
and under control but it's a great
pleasure to to welcome to the stage so
Mary Ann amatsu carto she is professor
in the economics of innovation and
public value and director of the
Institute for innovation at University
College London
she's advised policy makers all over the
world including her dear old Jeremy
Corbyn I believe for a relatively brief
period but nevertheless
dear old Jeremy Corbyn and she's authors
also two very very key books as well as
many others but two key books which
touch on these issues rethinking
capitalism and the entrepreneurial state
and she is about to have published her
book the value of everything makers and
takers in the global economy Matt
welcome Marianna Mervyn King I think the
first person on this stage that is not
only a lord
but is a double sir which must be a
first
so title inflation for Mervyn King but
maybe not much else and not my child
other inflation but Lord Mervyn King of
course governor of the Bank of England
2003 to 2013 one of the men credited
with being the architect of the
remarkable coming together of central
bank governors around the world without
them who knows what the effect of the
credit crisis the huge withdrawal of of
mainstream bank finance to the global
economy may have been Mervyn King one of
the architects of the remarkable
synchronized response of central banks
author of the end of alchemy money
banking in the future of the global
economy
welcome Lord King and on his left
Torsten bail director of the resolution
foundation think-tank which focuses on
standards of living on that incomes
issue in particular and how is it we can
make economies work for lower income low
and middle income people formerly
director of policy for the Labour Party
and worked in the Treasury a special
adviser to the Chancellor Alistair
Darling we are going to chitchat here
for a bit which you are welcome to
listen in to and then after about half
an hour 40 minutes or so I'm going to
come to questions from the audience
there will be people circulating with
microphones and little paddle boards so
look out for them as we get towards a
kind of about 750 and then we'll get a
good conversation going with you and
with us here
on stage so Mariana if I could start
with you and let's go let's go back to
the story
Marian about where you were at the time
of the financial crisis and I think that
also be interested in Mary as an
economist did it become clear to you and
that what moment was it Lehman was it
northern rock was it Rahl Bank of
Scotland was it you know what was going
on in Europe other issues that you were
looking at did you think it became clear
to you that this was something so
fundamental that possibly ten years on
we'll be talking about it in the same
way we still talk about the 1930s and
what it meant right so first so in
September 2008 I was it was during a
time that I was in Italy on maternity
leave and I had just had four children
in five years so I thought my problems
are much bigger than anything that I'm
seeing here in TV now and but I was
lucky that at the time I was directing
actually a big research project which
was very much related to the theme of
what I was seeing on TV happening that
night and the research project funded by
the European Commission which by the way
tends to fund a lot of the research that
many of us academics do and that's why
we're extremely worried about brexit was
called finance innovation and growth and
I remember when I was watching TV that
particular night I thought this is a
perfect conclusion which nightmare which
when did you think wow this is Wailing
woodland it was lame and I remembered
that I thought because I was actually
writing the conclusion for a report that
we were writing and the the whole grant
which was called finance innovation and
growth actually had been looking sector
by sector but also country by country at
the degree to which finance as a sector
had become dead linked to different
areas that we know actually caused
long-term growth not short-term kind of
speculative growth and my first kind of
question in my head was is this really
just about these particular banks or is
that actually about the financing model
of how the sector had again become
delinked but also the relationship
between finance and actually how
companies themselves were
being a if you want incentivized so this
whole issue around corporate governance
which I'm sure will come back to before
but the big question for me when I was
sort of seeing it sort of play out on
television was this is bigger than just
the banks how long will it take for the
conversation to move on and in fact I
think it took a very long time for it to
be a bigger question for too long I
think and partly that was why I don't
think we've reached the point where we
should be at too long it remained a
question of finance how do you reform
finance versus how do you actually
reform the system in which finance
should be kind of central in terms of
fostering and how many people mariana
did you think fundamentally shared how
many economists saw or people in the
finance sector or people in the
corporate world before the crisis really
bits and people the public had to engage
in it shared your concern that there is
this D linking between what growth
looked like it was doing and what was
actually happening
I'd say few but even in my little narrow
area which is the kind of economics of
innovation trying to really understand
what drives companies like Apple and
Microsoft what do we know about you know
what sort of brought them about I
remember that one of the things we kept
having to sort of stress in our
conversations with policy makers this is
before the crisis was stopped talking
about the need to have more finance
right this idea even if a credit crunch
or the fact that SMEs needed more
financing or that there wasn't enough
finance to do the kind of things that
were perceived as needed I remember that
we often myself and my team of
researchers this was not just a
individual battle we kept saying think
just as much about the quality of the
finance so you know even things that
were very different from lame and the
fact that you had a venture capital
sector which was increasingly short term
exit driven trying to exit in three
years through an IPO or a buyout we were
observing was really affecting in a very
negative way what at the time was the
kind of emergence of the biotech sector
and you had dysfunctions occurring in
the way that production distribution and
innovation were occurring because of the
quality of the fine
and yet you again kept falling back to
this notion of we need more money to do
stuff as opposed to let's really think
about the structure of the funds and the
finance and make sure that they're
structured properly because money and
finance are not neutral how you
structure finance actually affects what
happens in the real economy and that's
like a big point which I actually
continue to have to often talk about
finance is not neutral okay Marvin tell
us can you give us some insight to what
it was like being a central bank
governor as you became increasingly
aware or see before the collapses began
as you became increasingly aware that
something was so fundamentally
structurally wrong with our finance
system what what was the atmosphere like
in the bank and what did you need to do
well it was a lot calmer than people
might expect because those who watched
the crisis on television with you
actually it was a little bit like seeing
the highlights of a football match where
you see two minutes and any match looks
exciting if it you just show two minutes
and the ten minutes of news highlighted
in the evening made the thing look more
dramatic than it felt when you were
working very long hours and dealing with
individual banks and problems and you
work through them one by one
I think the the more difficult part of
it was trying to persuade people that
you know it's certainly by the end of
2007 well before Lehman Brothers it was
clear that our banking system needed to
be recapitalized that is it needed to
have more equity capital in the banks to
absorb losses and that there's no way
the banks could easily borrow money from
the rest of the economy if people had
lost confidence in it and they wouldn't
regain confidence unless the banks
looked much safer and I reckon it took
seven or eight months before we managed
to persuade people that this was the
problem that had to be tackled and I
think that the British government
took that lesson and the UK was in fact
the first country to recapitalize the
banks and I remember going to Washington
after the collapse of Lehman Brothers
and the Americans by that stage had
obtained money from Congress they wanted
to use that money to buy assets that had
fallen in value and they called them
troubled assets actually this would not
have been a very sensible thing because
the state would have been offered the
worst of those assets and instead they
used it to recapitalize their banks
following our model so I think that that
going through this there was no one
moment where you felt this is you know
drama there were lots of moments that
were critical and difficult and awkward
decisions had to be made but it was the
never ending it was you know in that
sense you mentioned Churchill earlier on
the second world war lasted less time
that it did in handling the financial
crisis and at every stage in that crisis
there were meetings which sometimes
lasted all night so and and staff were
up working hard to find a legal solution
to a problem that it arisen so I don't
think it was in that sense there was one
moment of drama there's no doubt that
the the dates that most people used to
date the crisis is the 9th of August
2007 when the French bank
PNB parabot announced that it wouldn't
allow any further redemptions from its
funds and then people started to and
they they pinned that on the US mortgage
market and then people started to become
worried and from there on you could see
the the state of the banking system
their ability to borrow money you know
waxing and waning during the time until
Lehman Brothers twelve months later
failed and then the whole of the Western
banking system would have collapsed had
it not been for state intervention can I
recite ly reformulate supposedly the
Queen's question which was so economists
why did nobody notice what was happening
before it happened I mean this was a
period up until 2007 or so in 2008 we
certainly started seeing the effects of
the banking crisis in
the real economy of the Great Moderation
Gordon Brown famously the end of boom
and bust in the UK there have been
criticisms that we became the bank
became too complacent about risk and
about financial sector risk in
particular how did you see it from
inside there were these signals but did
you feel that the system maybe the bank
itself had become a little complacent no
and I think I would go back if you asked
Mary honor what was the date of the when
the financial crisis began for me the
underlying causes of it go right back to
the fall of the Berlin Wall
and the transformation of many
previously centrally planned economies
into market economies they started to
save a lot of money particularly
obviously in Asia and from that date on
we saw this inexorable decline in
long-term interest rates when long-term
interest rates go down the prices of all
assets not just houses but also shares
and government bonds go up this is the
reverse of what's happened this week on
Friday and today and it went off for 25
years now all of this was visible it was
seen and we could see the problems that
arose from it we had a very unbalanced
world economy we had some countries
exporting a lot and others consuming a
lot we were in the consuming group
together with the United States China
and Germany were in the in exporting
group this could not go on that what was
clear but no one country on its own had
the ability to stop it happening it
would have required a coordinated
approach which was not feasible until a
crisis occurred it's very striking that
the only time you saw signs of
cooperation internationally was really
from the beginning of the crisis late
2007 particularly strongly in the autumn
of 2008 spring of 2009 with the g20 in
London which Gordon Brown shared but by
the end of 2009 the enthusiasm for
cooperation had disappeared and by 2010
it had gone why did you put that dancing
was that a mistake was that a prompt
that was a problem it's why I call him
I booked the prisoner's dilemma that is
that no one country or no one group of
politicians has any incentive to be the
first to sacrifice their domestic
interests and their own political
interests in favor of some global
cooperation and I think the IMF got
distracted
certainly in from 2010 onwards it got
badly distracted by the crisis in the
euro area and they got involved in that
in a way which you probably shouldn't
and it should have seen its role as
being out of the headlines not in the
publicity and on television and trying
to point out two countries the need not
to coordinate measures all do the same
thing but to agree on the diagnosis of
the problem and what had to happen to
put it right and I think my big concern
today is that the underlying problems
are still there so that the banking
system is much safer than it was indeed
the crisis might not have evolved
through the banking system it could have
come about through a crisis and exchange
rates and it that one might have
affected stock markets in fact it came
about through the banking system because
asset prices had risen very sharply as
interest rates came down people needed
to borrow more money to finance and to
purchase those assets and the banking
system did what it was supposed to do
which is to provide lending when people
demand it at the interest rate that
prevailed the real problem was that
interest rates were too low in many
parts of the world and that the banking
system did allowed itself to grow
rapidly without issuing more equity
capital so that they would be in a
position to absorb losses if and when a
crisis came we'll come back to whether
the banks are in or how safe the banks
are now and what threat they may still
pose to the global economy but Torsten
if I could come to you advice to
Alistair Darling Chancellor of course
through a lot of this cried I was always
I was always astonished speaking to
Alastair as I was fortunate to do
through a lot of this time and then
interview in post the sort of the rather
flabbergasted nature about how poor
poorly functioning
financial system was and that banks
didn't have this didn't seem to have the
most simple intelligence about how they
operated about what they operated about
the links between different bits of the
of their banking system sort of rank
ignorance of how they even worked
themselves well what do you put down
them the moment for you and tell us
where you were and what it felt like
being in that kind of political either
storm in the same way that Mervyn was in
the sort of set of the monetary or
central bank and financial stability I
have the store well events like this I'm
always slightly this is basically
reliving trauma yeah the textbooks say
you should only relive trauma it's quite
a dangerous thing to do you should only
do it with a really good therapist yeah
Lehman Brothers stands out as the moment
that the world where clearly
policymakers in this case US
policymakers had made a huge mistake and
that it was the only point where it
looked like Beck was an existential
crisis to the world's financial system
as opposed to individual countries
financial systems so there was clearly
existential crisis for the Irish
financial system which went bust and
similarly for Iceland by sailing brother
stands out as the kind of existential
moment for everybody and actually I'd
say the bit that highlights the best
bits of decision-making for the reasons
that Melvin says about pushing
recapitalisation as the underpinning
answer to the crisis the immediate
crisis them that's all stands out them
but I said the crisis more felt like I'm
not sure I quite agree with moving that
there was didn't feel like there was
quite a lot of drama I kind of could
have done with a lot less drama
so like Barry then ivan bet it seemed to
be every we every weekend every we were
working over the weekend to buy a
different bank or to bail out a
different bank or to reorganize a
balance sheet of a different financial
institution but then but it it more felt
like a long drag where every now and
again different issues would come to the
fore clearly Northern Rock in Britain
was the first big public noticeable
things over that had become clear over
August 2007 that they were problem
building and the northern walk was the
most likely fokin for them in the UK but
this what September the 13th 14th I
think it is in 2007 when it becomes
clear we've got institution that is
cannot go on and actually in retrospect
I think there's probably although it
although towards the end of 2007 early
2008 people start talking about at least
in private about the need for more
caftan lots of British banks the entire
banking sector is largely in denial
about that I think what you're getting
at Mervyn I mean the degree to which
people who ran our biggest banks and
member British banks at this point were
global banks mainly obvious is the
biggest bank in the world Barclays is a
huge international bank even banks that
you've never heard of had become pretty
international there at which people
would people on the boards even later on
in 2008 when you're seeing Bear Stearns
in the United States getting to serious
trouble would say to you we've got no
capital problem at all we've got we've
definitely got enough capital yes
there's a bit of a liquidity issue
because no one will give us any money
but if you just saw that out we've got
neighbors thought it was overnight
lending if overnight lending could be
fixed so some of them thought that yeah
the problem is that people are having at
they thought they had a version of a
bank run but it was manifesting itself
in people not lending to them overnight
as you say there and we used to have a
screen up in the one of the rooms in the
Treasury which had LIBOR which is the
rate of which banks can borrow overnight
showing what was happening to it that
was definitely not a good idea for blood
pressures it was largely doing this from
large chunks of this not always but for
most of this face so there so yes
definitely right up until individual
banks picked up the phone and said we
cannot go on and you have which was RBS
in the autumn after Lehman Brothers
their northern walk earlier most banks
boards were I don't I can't I don't to
say categorically whether they were
complacent as in they didn't think there
was a capital problem or they did not
want to have said there was a capital
problem until the point of crisis and if
it probably for different ones it was
probably different things and it is to
be fair quite hard to tell what looks
like a liquidity problem to one person
can look like a capital problem to
somebody else that's not completely
ridiculous but yes everybody right until
the point to which they were saying
we're going to close the
in three hours and they should do
something were leave as a conversation
team Philip Hampton and Alistair darling
yes that was one of the highlights yeah
that would have made it to the highlight
show it would have crept in I mean it
doesn't count to the goal I was the
first time in my life I wrote a check
for 35 billion pounds do you agree with
four stands point that if America had
had had a different approach to
recapitalisation at the beginning at the
time of LeMans some of the effects of
what happened
could have been mitigated no so I don't
think the America has made a mistake I
think we livin brothers the best they
could have done is nationalize it they
claim they didn't have the legal power
to do it that's not for me to say but I
think that even if they'd say that once
something else would have happened as we
saw in the two weeks after Lehman
Brothers failed so at one point or
another there would have been the need
to recapitalize the whole system and I
think once people had understood that
then they wouldn't doubtedly have been
the realization that there was a major
problem and the problem would have gone
away until the banks had actually been
recapitalized
in the states that occurred in May 2009
and I think you can that's the point
where the banking crisis as such ended
some banks still needed to do more work
but people were confident that the
system would carry off but I think the
the extent to which we got into a
position in but which banks had borrowed
too much money were over leveraged in
that sense we was there in 2007
beginning of 2008 and the banks as
Torsten said were in denial they
adamantly refused to admit that this was
the case many of the bigger banks had
leverage ratios of 40 or 50 to one which
meant that for every two pounds that
they put in a shareholders money you
know 898 pounds were borrowed well it
most businesses if you borrowed 98
percent of your total capital you're
very fragile to say the least
northern rock had a leverage ratio of
eighty to one extraordinary thing of
course is
with northern rock that according to the
new international regulations introduced
in Britain at the beginning of 2007
northern rock could say and did say that
they were the best capitalized bank in
the UK and that's because the
regulations and this is my criticism but
much of what's happened in the
regulatory front it takes years to draw
up international agreements and
regulations by the time those
regulations came in the assumption was
that the safest lending the banks can
make were mortgages and that it didn't
matter how you financed yourself well
both of those were very bad assumptions
and yet once the regulatory train had
started you couldn't stop it and direct
it onto a different track we still got
that problem today we still have that
regulation is sort of in the rearview
mirror
I mean we've we reckon that the capital
requirements have been redefined etc but
it's still based on a view that a group
of people beating together in Basel from
different countries think they know
enough about the future to judge which
assets are safe and which are riskier
and I think that's an assumption of
knowledge which is a very dangerous
thing to believe in and it's better the
regulation works best when it's simple
not when it gets so complicated that
people devise very detailed rules which
may be have been perfect if we had
applied them ten years ago but by the
time the next crisis comes these rules
will not eventually done what level
would you put the chance of another
financial breakdown of a similar level
to what we experienced in 2007-2008 well
the banking system as such is still
risky in the sense that banks borrow
short and lend long and if the people
who've led to banks for short term maybe
not just overnight but for three months
decide that it's too risky to lend to
the bank for three months because after
all you know if you're really if you
think something nasty could happen to a
bank why take the risk of lending for
three months to the bank you just get
your money out and lend it to someone
else for three months
until the the nervousness has gone away
banks are still fragile in that sense
and we don't have a mechanism for doing
anything other than throwing money at it
if the crisis were to occur and I think
it's not difficult to see how where
another crisis could come the amount of
debt in the world today is higher even
just in the private sector than it was
in 2007 relative to GDP so there's
plenty of scope in the next decade
for not this time a French bank to
announce that some of its funds can't be
redeemed but for a few people maybe in
China maybe in emerging markets the
European Bank or to to say we can't
repay our debts once that happens and
people ask the question well the value
of the assets on financial institutions
around the world is the value of the
loans that they've made but if these
loans can't be repaid then their assets
aren't worth as much as they say they
are and in which case the bank looks
very fragile indeed so we have not got
to a point where we would be able to
claim that the we are immune to another
crisis that doesn't mean to say one is
around the corner and of course you know
toasters description of banks being in
denial of thinking they were fine that
isn't true of banks today the people and
running banks today are only too
conscious that things can go badly wrong
but of course at some point the people
who remembered the last crisis and who
worked in banks will have retired and at
that point banks will be run again by
people who think wow this is terrific
you know nothing can go wrong but I mean
this is a natural human emotion I
remember being a student in the 1960s
and thinking about the Great Depression
and I thought you know we're learning
Keynesian economics there will never be
a Great Depression again we know how to
deal with it and when you looked at the
photographs of people from the 1930s boy
did they look like fuddy-duddies and
hats and whiskers you know we were
modern we would never let this happen
again
well we didn't have a Great Depression
in most of the industrialized countries
Greece certainly did southern Europe has
certainly had something comparable to
that but nevertheless we had the deepest
recession since the Great Depression and
a collapse of the banking system which
required massive state intervention not
in order to protect the banks but in
order to protect the economy from the
banks Mariana
give us your view of where the economy
is now and how linked I raised a few of
the structural issues of the something
developed economies are facing at the
moment how linked is that to the way
that finance is still working and what
is your view about the huge move by
central banks and govern governments to
recapitalize the banks did they save the
banks from themselves and therefore save
the economy or did they actually simply
cover with a wash a huge wash of money
the fundamental problems that are still
there right so I mean coming back to my
earlier comments I think that and in
some ways I haven't heard this
perspective in terms of what the really
kind of structural dysfunctions were in
the economy where some of what you guys
were talking about was kind of the
symptom of the sickness right and what I
would say was the structural kind of
cause which I would argue is still there
today and hence one should be extremely
worried today and as you just mentioned
the the ratio of private debt to
disposable income is basically at record
levels and that's what caused the
financial crisis it was private debt not
public debt but the actual structural
composition of the economies is still
very sick because the diagnosis was the
wrong one and why I think it's sick is
you have two types of financialization
on the one hand you have a financial
sector that's basically still obsessed
with itself in other words finance
finances finance only something like 15
percent of funds from the sector and by
that I mean the widely defied defined
sector actually goes into the real
economy into business right
and then you have the real economy so
businesses in different industries
whether it's pharmaceuticals IT or
energy which are also financialized so
they're not just they're sort of
innocent little businesses needing the
finances which isn't coming to them by
financialized business I mean businesses
that increasingly these are especially
the large businesses for example the S&P
500 which are increasingly so it's
getting worse
spending their profits instead of
reinvesting the profits back into
production innovation new machinery
capital expenditures in areas like share
buybacks so boosting stock prices which
boost stock options which boosts
surprise-surprise executive pay now both
of these problems then really hurt the
economy right so this whole issue for
example of you know the robots are
taking our jobs they're not taking our
jobs robots or if you think of it in
terms of mechanization has been around
for about 200 years
you know David Ricardo already back in
1821 wrote a book called principles of
political economy or chapter 31 don't
ask me why I remember this both on
machinery was like oh we're in trouble
you know all these machines are taking
jobs and they're gonna reduce wages but
then what you had for 200 years since
then was that fine some jobs might be
you know taken in this area but as long
as profits from the the investment in
those machineries were then reinvested
back in the economy new jobs are us so
when you have this financialized real
economy you get a break in that
mechanism so you no longer have the
profits going back in which kind of
creates a creative destruction kind of
dynamic and so this this this is a huge
problem and this I would argue is one of
the key problems in terms of wage
stagnation we've had wage stagnation
since the 1980s so when we do look at
private debt figures it's also because
people have had to in some ways just to
retain existing living standards take
out debts right it's not that they were
just so foolish oh these stupid people
taking out debt that they shouldn't have
been they actually had to in order to
compensate for for these stagnant wages
which were partly I would say greatly a
cause of
this of these prophets not being
reinvested and I would say that both
these elements of financialization have
not been tackled a company like Apple by
the way under Steve Jobs almost all the
profits under jobs were be invested back
into the company under Tim Cook Apple
has become one of the most financialized
companies with you know over 100 billion
share buyback schemes you know so
corporate governance how businesses are
structured matters and the big change
was from the 1980s onward so I would
agree that their problem began in the
1980s where this kind of notion that the
that the point of companies is to
maximize shareholder value is actually
quite a recent change and those are
revolution before that there was more
this idea of stakeholder value that
there is different actors in the economy
that produced value and you know workers
in a company and you know public actors
etc were just as important as the
shareholder and lastly the just the Cold
War you know mentioned that you made so
1989 I would say that just almost in a
cartoon image wise one could also argue
that the crisis also began when some of
the smartest people in the world so some
of the top scientists in Eastern Europe
ended up going to Wall Street and
someone once told me a joke that you
know the financial crisis was basically
caused when you had this massive shift
before that you had you know people in
say a college classroom the smartest
ones ended up being the managers and the
kind of dumb jocks went to go in Wall
Street when you had a reverse of that
the smartest people going to Wall Street
and some of the dumb people becoming
managers but this huge reversal of where
energy and expertise went no matter
let's go we're coming up to where I want
to bring in the audience but let's go
for the three of you but same question
you've given it the diagnosis quite a
lot of diagnoses of why the economy's is
where it is give us just two solutions
that could pull us out of the situation
we find us in well the first is and this
is sort of a separate what just then as
a continuation of what I just said so
it's more logical we need to define an
shil eyes
economy there also has to be incentives
for that currently we actually have
incentives which reward companies which
are short-term and speculative over
those that actually invest in the long
run so something like capital gains tax
and this was actually labor in this
country that did this capital gains
taxes structured extremely badly so that
it was the Labour Party that reduced the
time that private equity had to be
invested from ten years to two years to
get this massive tax reduction that's
really not very smart if you actually
want companies to be investing in the
long term but secondly there's no point
in creating all this money just to save
the economy right trillions were created
both in the UK and in the u.s. unless
you all saw at the same time creating
opportunities for those investments and
hence we need really smart and strategic
what I would call mission oriented
fiscal policy in the economy which
actually creates the opportunities
whether it's around green investments
the green economy a new form of sort of
Digital Agenda if you do that seriously
then this creation of money does more
than just save the banks because that
money just ended up back in the banks it
didn't find its way towards the real
economy so what kind of macro sort of
solution is you better have smart
strategic you know fiscal policy aligned
with this monetary policy and on the
micro level deep financial eyes big
business because that's bad for skills
it's bad for an innovation it's very
good for inequality inequality is rising
because of that now Torsten you're
you're the resolution foundation looks
at a lot of these issues has certainly
identified and we've done a lot of work
with you certainly identified how real
people are experiencing the economy now
and why there is this reaction maybe
against capitalism what do you see is
some of the solutions Mariano's
obviously said that the financial system
itself needs to be reformed and the tax
system around that and maybe governments
need to be bolder in themselves in being
innovators and being entrepreneurial and
having some kind of mission mission led
approach what's awesome for you and the
foundation would be things that the the
government the businesses not just all
see governor's don't run economies
businesses should be doing to re-engage
the
public in the notion that the capitalist
market might actually be the best form
there is a good start would be to step
back and say because at the moment we're
you know we're talking about lots of
individual dates what happened in April
then what happened did in the following
autumn when the history books are
written to cover that period they are in
kind of 10-15 years time they'll
basically say just two things they'll
say Britain had the biggest financial
crisis in its history and then it left
the European Union basically I think the
question and whatever you think about
the the decision to leave the European
Union I'm gonna take a punt on where
this audience is but that's obviously
not where the whole country will be the
whatever you think about that that
that's a pretty suboptimal result from
ten years disaster basically there
because whatever you think about a lot
of the fundamental problems that we are
facing as an economy were there yes I
mean but what I'm trying to get to up
before the Princip what no no there's
not any break see results call the
improvements yet right there I make I'm
just making appointment just the history
books will say that what should they
have said Britain had a huge financial
crisis it dealt with that financial
crisis actually pretty well in the short
term yeah but then it took a good hard
look at itself and started sorting out
some of the underpinning problems that
were there so for example that said that
said well we've put up with the level of
wealth being accumulated by each
generation whatever falling for
everybody born after 1955 yeah
so you Pete who was born in like around
1955 anyone you are like you are peak
wealth for Britain
maybe not you personally may not feel
like that all the time but that's
because measured about the big check
there but that was the like and we've
been going backwards ever since then so
actually so for example a generation
born in the early in the first five
years of the 1980s the first half an
idea that's you with modern politics you
love all these lies has half the wealth
at the same age as people born just five
years before half
yeah somebody a man in Manchester today
is earning the same as a man in
Manchester 17 years ago 7-0 now 1 7 1 7
this bigger problems in and when that
it's those things as it's the facts like
that as much as you know what exactly
has happened to individual banks
actually don't think the problem the
next problem for Britain is not banks
are gonna go bust again and that's that
will come when people forget why they we
needed these tough regulations in the
first time I open now is I'm problem our
problem is that too many people look at
our country in our colony and say if
that's the best we can do it's not good
enough and the problem is they're kind
of right so that is I think things we
should be doing or addressing those
problems we should be building houses
and then restricting people's ability to
buy second third and other houses if we
want to change what the outcome people
are saying baby boomers had a 50% higher
homeownership rate of 30 than today's
millennials millennials on average have
spent forty four thousand pounds more on
rent in their twenties than the baby
boomers which is roughly a deposit on a
house at the mmm now a slightly unfair
but the my point is that is what people
are asking for they're saying how come
we've now got 1.6 million people with
fat with kids living in the private
rented sector which was just six hundred
thousand ten years ago yet we've done
nothing to increase security for
families in the prior renter sector so
yes we should sort out our financial
system yes we should sort out our
economic theory and our convoluted you
know ideas that underpin a lot of what
we do in terms of policy what people
really want isn't different economic
theories they want different economics
they want us to address some
bread-and-butter issues about better
jobs better housing cheaper housing and
a better stand that is the UH that's the
real disaster the last ten years is that
the energy from the crisis has not been
used to fix any of those problems do you
think Mervyn that the emergency moves
that were made to rescue particularly
the developed world economies has
actually had as many positive effects as
you may have hoped for or to go back to
Marianas point has in fact yes you saved
the banks but actually the money just
went into the banks to saving them and
really promote this type of economic
reform for real people that might have
been expected no I think the measures
that were taken were necessary but they
weren't sufficient and I think if you
look it's very important to distinguish
between incomes and wealth here they're
different phenomena so if we take the
figures that Torsten mention which are
really quite extraordinary about how the
age at which people become homeowners
has risen so dramatically in such a
short period of time I think that is
entirely accounted for by the fact that
long-term real interest rates have
fallen to such low levels that house
prices relative to incomes have reached
extraordinarily high levels that was an
almost mechanical consequence of very
low interest rates now the consequence
is that people in my generation found
that on paper at least we seemed much
wealthier because our houses are worse
phenomenal amounts of money because not
clear you can do anything with this
unless you want to live in a field in a
tent ok
nevertheless it means that younger
people cannot borrow the money to become
homeowners
now the point about this is that as
interest rates go back to normal levels
which I hope over 5-10 years they will
then that situation will reverse and
house prices will fall relative to
incomes in other words we may be in for
a long period of very stagnant house
prices and the new young in 20 years
time will actually be just as well off
as I was in my generation it's the
current generation that will lose out
they will have bought houses if they had
been able to do at the peak and they'll
be selling them at the trough so that's
the wealth aspect which I think time and
higher interest rates will resolve
incomes is a different issue because
total income in this country as it is in
the United States and most of the
industrialized world is about 15% below
where we would have expected it to be at
the beginning of 2007 by now and I don't
think that is something which is easy to
change without greater cooperation in
the world economy to get back to a more
balanced structure I I don't want to
deny that the issues that Mariana raised
aren't important they are but
nevertheless this big gap between where
we should be and where we are is I think
directly the result of the fact that we
failed to deal with the structural
imbalances in the world economy this is
a macroeconomic issue and we have to get
that sorted out and I think the
unfortunate thing was that whereas in
2008 2009 central banks were absolutely
at the you know key point of dealing
with this crisis people then thought how
all central banks can do miracles and
they are the only game in town actually
the role of central banks should have
been diminished from you know 2011 and
12 onwards and the policy responses
should have been focused on other issues
but as I say I don't think any one
country would have found it easy to get
out of this on its own and they haven't
but I mean we've been talking about
structurally global structural
imbalances for decades saver countries
don't want to give up being saver
countries and debtor comp countries are
then stuck being debtor countries and
there is never any structural movement
is there to keep whacking our move - in
the end there is because what will
happen is that has happened in the
interwar period the debtor countries
default and the surplus countries which
have lent the money and feel they're
very affluent because they own lots of
claims on other countries actually don't
own anything of any value and when they
realized that that would be a big shock
so if the irony in a way is that Germany
with a very large current account
surplus eight to nine percent of GDP is
accumulating each year almost ten
percent of its income annual income and
investing it in claims on other
countries during the interwar period it
was the other way round and it was the
Germans who pointed out quite rightly
but how on earth could they be expected
to repay debt and meet war reparations
if they weren't allowed to earn an
exporter
which will give them the money to repay
the debt and if we are pushing countries
into a situation where they can't get
out of this trap then in the end we shed
Yuling of debt on a large scale becomes
inevitable moran just forget when we
talk about the world i think we should
also admit that there was huge
differences actually in how the world
reacted to the crisis so you know obama
had a 800 billion stimulus program we
kind of forgot to do that here so there
was this kind of almost for the first
time I think since world war two
countries in Europe deciding to be
procyclical after a crisis right I mean
the point of counter cyclical policies
and I'm talking about mainly fiscal
policies is you know to get you out of
recession so it doesn't turn into a
depression and if you look at the data
before World War Two the four sort of
Keynes and economics came into fashion
there was actually depressions not just
recessions every 20 or so years and so
the fact that both in the UK call that
austerity call it what you want but this
lack of serious stimulus and in Europe
in the eurozone this kind of failure to
really diagnose the problems of the
weakest countries the so called pigs I'm
Italian so a lot to say it but Portugal
Italy Greece and Spain as a beautiful
word coined by Goldman Sachs where those
countries actually were quite weak not
because they had been spending too much
but because they had been spending
really kind of stupidly so Italy for 20
years had a zero growth in productivity
is GDP almost hadn't grown in terms of
growth rate and in that period and so
what they actually needed was to rethink
you know the role of public but also
private investment private investment
had been quite an Arsenal in Italy so
this kind of you know eurozone kind of
mentality that these weak countries and
just you know simply needed to cut their
public debt in order to get out of the
crisis was an obvious huge mistake the
UK which failed to have a stimulus
program was a huge mistake and would
this lack of growth that you're saying
should have you know come back since the
crisis you know would we have this
stalemate have there been a serious
fiscal stimulus and I think it'd be very
hard to argue that it was purely
imbalance between two thicknesses
replying then we must go to be okay very
very the problem in the euro area was
not that they had austerity as such but
they had nothing else they have no they
needed a weaker exchange rate they
needed to devalue the UK had a 25%
depreciation of sterling and it was
reasonable to expect that if you want to
rebalance the UK economy to encourage
resources to shift to exports you have a
big boost to the incentive to export and
to cut back on import substitutes
through a depreciation weight and then
and then I'm gonna need to cut some
domestic spending so I don't think that
was that was the big issue there are
plenty of things going wrong and there
are big issues that orsten referred to
about intergenerational inequality that
need dealing with but they're quite
separate I think from wealth and income
the well form will come right when we
get interest rates back the incomes warm
or not okay fantastic questions
questions questions now we have lots of
people walking around with sort of
paddler balls and things there's a
anyway this red one here should be great
in terms of the stagnation we have had
over the past ten years and argue longer
in wages is the magic bullet now we have
to wait for technology to kick into gear
we have to wait for things like
artificial intelligence or the
room-temperature superconductor for
example that will dramatically increase
productivity and is that the magic
bullets get wages up and get debt get
debt down do we have to hold out for
technology to come to our aid source it
is gonna save the world technology I
mean probably not there's a lot of
things going on in your question I mean
in a very short term the thing Mervin
said right at the end there which is
about this big depreciation of sterling
what happened in 2008-2009 but if people
thought the Britain was particularly
affected by this crisis and actually
repeated itself on a smaller scale off
to the BRICS it vote I actually think
one of the things looking back from our
said earlier what are the big mistakes
we made one of the mistakes is we
thought that every recession was like
the last recession so all the planning
meetings about what we were going to do
to deal with this crisis
apart from leaving aside saving the
banks and west
for the real world were what unimportant
we'll hit three million as it had in the
80s and 90s repossessions will go
through the roof and insolvent seas will
increase significantly all three
predictions that were wrong now and
there's reasons for that although the
big one is low interest rate environment
that was not the same as the 80s and 90s
the big thing we missed is that that
depreciation fed through to a very big
spike along with some oil price changes
in inflation around that time the
suppressed real wages significantly
nowhere we haven't seen before
and we've actually never seen before and
then right the way through from then
till 2014 wages are falling and we're
now we then had a small mini boom in
2014-15 bit of 16 which was basically
very low inflation not it's not the
wages it's not that everyone's been
getting wage rises inflation was just
very low then now and then since brexit
high inflation again falling real wages
again so even today ten years on from
the financial crisis real wages are 15
pounds a week lower than they were at
the time of the crisis now what's going
to get us out of that well
inflation is slowly recede likely to
recede slightly will technology get it
out of that not what is well I think
that well technology is where it is I
don't think one is I mean Mariana's much
better place to talk about what we can
do to boost that but that is that is
kind of happening I don't think that is
that can be the answer though to our you
know the reasons when firms need to
invest to use technology if you look at
we spent on up in Sheffield you can
spend time with the manufacturing firms
there and you wonder why let Sheffield
has a very high level of low pay it's
not the technology doesn't exist
it's the firms do not use it heute like
they have very bad management and they
have very low take-up of technology and
you say to them you know how's things
going in Sheffield and they say oh well
it's going okay and you say no it's
really not you know it's really not or
you say to some of our sectors so in
hospitality today 61% of the workforce
is low paid 61% and you say - you know
there are constraints clearly there when
people don't want to pay more than half
- for the hotel room or their food but
we have also got business models based
on not taking up technology in some
cases now what's happening right now is
a big experiment actually this area
because in Britain what we're about to
do is significantly reduce our input of
low paid labour and we're putting up the
price of
paid labor the earnings inequality in
Britain is falling quite significantly
in the moment because of the National
living wage the minimum wage is rising
fast and everybody else is basically
flat yeah so earnings inequalities for
overall inner court is not falling but
earnings of equality is falling and for
the labour market that combined with
falling migration is a huge huge change
and that is actually what is more likely
I think it's more likely that the
minimum wage higher wages will push
technology as in if it's more expensive
to hire people you instead go and get
some technology rather than technology
causing the mariana yeah I overheard a
big sigh from you there what were you
worried about so I would say well it is
technology occurs within sort of a
system right and technology has never
been the sort of panacea even think of
mass production which was a huge
technological kind of revolution
actually organisational revolution of
how production occurred which many
researchers have shown actually then
created all sorts of growth in the
economy that wouldn't have happened
without other things happening at the
same time in that particular instance
without suburbanization people actually
moving to the suburbs these new
mass-produced things whether there were
cars or washing machines would not have
actually become fully diffused and fully
deployed throughout the whole economy so
when today and if you know Robert Gordon
but he's quite funny when he does this
when he puts up the indoor toilet here
and the internet there and says you know
if you had to get rid of one which would
you get rid of and then they'd gone
outside today right in this point being
you know God actually electricity in the
indoor toilet have done much more for
our economy than the internet where
people are just you know on their job
searching for whatever shopping on
Amazon that kind of misses the point
which the real question should be have
we actually had today some ambitious
policies that have actually allowed for
example ICT information and
communication technologies to get fully
deployed and fully diffused throughout
the whole economy and could we for
example imagine some really bold green
policies all the stuff about sustainable
cities but also the kind of energy then
the kind of policies that they have in
German
to provide a new direction also for IT
let alone all these new sort of you know
advents and things like AI and Big Data
those as well could be used for some
things or others and I'm always struck
by how you know there's this lack of
application for example of Big Data to
certain social problems so remember the
bedroom tax right it was like the
stupidest equation it's like how many
bedrooms do you have how many children
do you have it's once bigger than the
other you're out right so in a world of
big data wouldn't it have been
interesting if we had really you know
complex algorithms and not just + - /
equals whatever to actually make much
more informed decisions on things like
housing policy and you know improve the
welfare state through the use of AI and
big data versus simply allowing big data
to you know basically improve things
like personalized medicine so there's
choices to be made on how we use
existing technologies to really
distribute them through advances in the
real economy including improving the
welfare state which i think is under
incredible stress right now but also any
of these new innovations not just
existing technologies the new ones won't
actually create long run productivity
and long run growth without also these
demand-side policies and personally I
think those demand-side policies must
bring us to a new greener form of
production distribution and consumption
Thanks all rights gentlemen hey tez
Patrick senior economists with the
Institute for Economic Affairs day -
direct associate director please your
floor is yours for a second or two thank
you so it strikes me like a key theme
here is the role of short-termism it
clearly played a massive role on trading
floors during the financial crisis but
it also played a key role in terms of
policymaking and regulation in terms of
not being able to horizon scan and
foresee risks now myopia is a very
inherent inbuilt human aspect and
obviously at the Institute of Directors
we work with businesses to try and
improve their corporate governance
models to kind of shift from the
short-term focus and profiteering to
looking at
long-term value creation that creates
more sustainable business models I think
the challenge really is is how we can
transfer that long term governance to
the policymakers and policymaking
because inherently the political cycle
is five years long and when we're trying
to deal with crises in the global
economy whether that's through
technology through financial risk we
need to start thinking decades ahead so
I was wondering what solutions or
innovations you might have to our
institutional structures that could try
and engender that long term ism in our
political system
Moman did you have how much of an issue
was the short-termism of the political
process and the need for results in that
type of cycle that Ted touches on in
terms of making long-run sensible
regulatory decisions the notion of true
or otherwise light touch regulation was
a way of encouraging financial centers
to locate in London and that we were
going to be the friend of the financial
centers so I two comments on this one
about business and what about government
and politicians on the business front I
used to every month go out and visit to
region in the UK economy and visit lots
of companies and over the years I was
governor I meant to offer a lot of
companies and one thing which struck me
was that the best companies I saw were
very often private companies and the
reason was that they weren't subject to
this tyranny of the quarterly reporting
season in which they were supposed to
say why haven't your earnings gone up by
10 percent over the previous quarter
they actually could say well we believe
in what we do and we have a product we
think will succeed we want to make it
work and all the people I met who
impressed me even in very rundown
factories even if family firms but the
same people were directors as the great
great great grandfather's 150 years ago
what distinguished them from companies
that weren't so successful was that they
were passionate
about the product that they were making
that could be pleats in stoke-on-trent
it could be bred in different places I
went to could be any steel anything
engineering products but they were all
passionate about their product so I do
think short tourism short termism
brought about by this focus on very
short term returns on assets and short
term volatility is a major issue the
second one in government is I was always
struck by how many of the politicians I
work with were very focused not just on
tomorrow morning's headlines but on
tonight's stories on BBC so they didn't
wait to the next month they were
focusing on what was in there and that's
is what generates an excessive focus on
you know short term announcements a
policy has become announcements rather
than thinking about measures that are
implemented
you know the good old days there were
this is a slight exaggeration but
there's a real kernel of truth to it
when people were elected and be formed a
government they breathed the sigh of
relief and said well we don't have to
campaign anymore for another four or
five years we can actually focus on
governing for four or five years no
longer
I think after Bill Clinton we were in a
world now in which you win in an
election and the next day you start
campaigning all over again and that
focus on short-termism
really does alter the ability of
politicians to feel that they're not
under the pressure to come up with some
immediate answer you know every day
they're expected to make statements to
answer questions to have answers to
everything I mean I used to go to the
House of Commons Treasury Committee and
I'd say quite often I don't know they
regarded this as a totally appalling
answer and but for politicians
politicians are asked many questions on
every subject on every single one
they're expected to have the answer yeah
that makes absolutely no sense because
then you do get superficial responses
it's very shortly tossing in Meritor
some what's your sense of Tara's point
about the governance issue we marinate
touching is a lot actually you're saying
is it's the key issue alongside
financialization I mean Torsten is that
is the problem that businesses are just
poorly run and also just to poke a bit
at Murphy and the notion of private
companies of course in terms of
transparency you give up a lot long in
terms of being able to scrutinize
private companies in return maybe for
this more long-term focus yeah I mean on
so on I think your question was
shouldn't politics learn a bit more from
the increasingly long-term business I
think I'm probably a bit more on the
both of rubbish at it on on the purely
on the private companies I mean I agree
with Mervyn on private broadly defined
that is my experience visiting companies
two of I'm a visiting a company up in
Cambridge a few years back and they said
to me they said the company up in I
think it been the late 80s I said how
did you get your company set up and they
said I've never had anybody else give
this answer they said we had a loan from
Barclays and I said alright and I said
what kind of loan a 30 year loan from
Barclays but the mode to get a 5 year
loan from Barclays now you'd probably
have to put your house up again you
would have to put your house up against
it this company had gotten on you know
unsecured 30-year loan which they had
run their business on they have no
quarterly reporting except insofar as
they wanted it themselves
so that is definitely well I'm not sure
I agree about family-run firms being
because of the productivity challenge
for lots of them but clearly some are
very good but you do see a big
productivity drop-off when you pass a
firm over to the kids in general you
can't trust your kids to run your
company it turns out they're on the
politics short-termism
yeah so Mervyn is 100% right that the
the pressures are definitely I want to
sound holier-than-thou now but the
pressures are significant the structural
pressures towards short-termism are real
and significant 24-hour media cycle
everything you've read about people like
this hassling you you just wish they'd
stop hassling you they're like this why
you me sorry these two are fine right
okay there it's a last bit irritating
but all I would say without before we
get kind of let all politicians off the
hook again when we reflect back on this
decade in particular in sort of the
phase post bricks I do you think some of
it is it's not just about the structure
it's about the leadership
it's about haha do people see it is
their job to bring the country together
again and to chart a kind of different
direction as I was saying that addresses
some of these core underlying problems
or is it just what can I do to kind of
exploit this division or play this game
now and AH my view is that it is not the
prompters that are to blame for the lack
of that it is a leadership vacuum yep
number three yes where I carry on number
three and then number four number three
there's a the general just in front of
here has always been waiting for honor
but number three yes sir the new
populist are in the business of stoking
up anger and then directing it all Peter
can you introduce yourself Peter yorck
the new populist are in the business of
stoking up anger and then they direct it
or they redirect it they divert it but
who should people be angry with by which
I mean the victims of the situation you
will describe the financialization
situation finance finances finance most
wonderful phrase ever and how should
that anger be seen as relating to the
anger that has been stoked up the anger
that's been stoked up by Trump and the
anger that's been stoked up by the
brexit merchants how do they align
Thank You Peter let's have a number four
just hang on before we come to that
number four good evening I wanted to
engage with some of the points Mariana
raised specifically I think an
oversimplified argument about share
buybacks so this isn't really about
boosting executive pay I think the
bigger issue here is in the quality and
the implications that so when you have
elevated asset prices who that really
benefits are people who have pensions or
in the house or have an icer so what
what that argument really relates to
isn't productivity and the misspending
or the productivity dividend is to do
with those who own assets on the right
or center of wealth distribution and
those on the left side of wealth
distribution who don't own any assets
and then the second point connect to
this is this really dangerous idea about
picking
winners in the economy so this idea of
fiscal spending targeted at specific
industries we try that in this country
and ended in the 1970s we need to avoid
going back to policies like that thank
you thank you very much so I'm over I'm
gonna stop with Peters question who
should the people be angry with and who
have Trump and the what did you say
Peter the brexit the brexit is have they
been stoking up anger of a different
type so who should people be angry with
first off about the situation they fight
harder to do it the other way around
because I don't think the anger has been
stoked up from nothing the anger was
there I remember at the Bank of England
during and after the financial crisis
the immediate aftermath of it holding
dinners at the bank where I would ask
people why is it the case that we're not
seeing more anger I had expected that
we'd see more anger now I think the
measures taken by central banks and
governments to prevent unemployment
rising as much it did rise but it didn't
rise as much as it did in the Great
Depression helped to put a lid on the
anger in the short term but I think
people could see as time passed that
since the the cost of the crisis in
terms of GDP was very real and it was
spread perhaps more on lower-income
people's and higher income people the
anger was there it was genuine and it
was real so I think that you know much
of what we've seen in the last few years
in right across countries it's not just
the UK it's not just the u.s. with Trump
I think in Europe two people have been
voting not for candidates but against
the establishment and the people who
were there before so I think there was a
real sense of anger as Torsten said
earlier that actually the the economy is
not delivering what they had bought into
after all in the previous 25 years
people have been told very much by
people in the financial sector that if
they would accept market discipline
a more flexible labor market if you work
for a company and there aren't any
customers you shouldn't expect the
government to bail you out if they
accepted this approach to market
discipline then productivity will grow
faster incomes would rise would all be
better off and of course it looks as
though that it worked except when it
came to the financial crisis the market
discipline didn't seem to be applied to
the banks it wasn't they were bailed out
now that was done for good reason to
prevent not the banks from suffering but
other people but nevertheless it looked
like that and so on this this anger is
very real and I think that we've seen it
come through I predicted it would come
through and we've seen it right across
the industrialized world and it it is in
my view of correlated with countries
that experienced the financial crisis
you don't see this in the same way
anywhere near as much in Asia which had
their own financial crisis much earlier
or Latin America so it's a crisis of the
industrialized world now the anger I
think is the it's it's at the way we
have chosen to govern ourselves and our
economy and it's I would put it more
deeply as saying it's that people should
be angry about an intellectual failure
it's a failure of ideas to put forward
solutions to the problems which they see
us
is it being fair to them by sir mine
Peter mentioned Trump Peter mentioned
BRICS it is it being fed by people who
want to break the present system in a
way that is good for them and but it
could be negative more broadly now I
think that if you look at the United
States so we don't get bogged down in
brexit here look at the United States
which is perhaps the most extreme case
there is absolutely no doubt that the
elite is represented by Hillary Clinton
welcome absolutely there was no sign
that they actually understood the
problems that were being suffered by
many people in the rest of the United
States and the opioid crisis in the u.s.
has led to mortality of white people
overall rising in the u.s. not true of
the black population not true of this
panic population it is true the white
population
it's basically largely people with lower
levels of educational entertainment but
the last time we saw mortality rising
was when the Soviet Union broke up and
we thought that rising mortality was a
sign of chaos in Russia alcoholism and
so on we have it here in the United
States and it's coming to the UK with
beginning to see increases in mortality
here and what do people think is the big
issue it's political correctness it's
other issues it isn't actually getting
to grips with the problems that many
ordinary people feel they face that is
the crisis and that's where much of the
anger is coming from
marie-anne how do you respond to these
so I'll take both just really quickly so
this year on share buybacks so you're
you basically just outlined what happens
after that right which is that asset
prices then get inflated but the point
of share buybacks is this whole issue of
reinvestment by the way we've been
looking at the degree to which you have
the share buybacks of which many you
know the extent to which we have them
was actually illegal it was actually
illegal under the Securities and
Exchange Commission in the 1980s and
then all of a sudden it was sort of
allowed and I would argue that this is a
crisis of the kind of deals that are
being struck so when you have a record
level hoarding which we have in both
Europe and the US over two trillion
dollars being hoarded so inert to
capital in the u.s. over two trillion
euros in Europe record level
financialization and again just look at
the share buyback figures just the
extent to which they've increased that's
also a reflection of the lack of in some
ways confidence coming back to the
public sector so not just politicians
but the public sector agencies which are
often giving out these massive subsidies
of which some may be problematic and
I'll get to that in a second used to
actually be in exchange for the private
sector doing its part which was
investing so coming back to the issue of
innovation Bell Labs which you might
have heard of which was one of the most
famous kind of private sector R&D
laboratories actually came from a period
in history where the US government in
order to grant a monopoly in this case
to
TNT said you know these profits that are
being generated from a government
granted not God granted monopoly have to
be reinvested back into the economy into
innovation big innovation beyond
telecoms and that's where Bell Labs was
formed and I would argue that the recent
Karelian and capita crisis here this
issue around outsourcing it's not about
public or private it's the lack of deal
you don't just give out a contract even
to virgin with the rail without making
it conditional on the private actors
than investing in the improvement of the
rail and improvement of the health
system or the prisons versus even
allowing that to become or short-term
sort of speculative area in terms of the
picking winners I mean to be honest that
is the most ideological debate obviously
we should not go back to the 1970s style
just kind of picking a firm or a sector
one of the ways to really revive
industrial strategies to take which by
the way this country is trying to do
with Greg Clark is to take away the
emphasis on sectors and to focus on
problems what are the big problems
afflicting British society and
especially perhaps choosing those that
have some sort of societal value that
citizens care about but transforming
them into problems that require
investment across many different sectors
going to the moon require 12 different
sectors 400 homework problems of which
200 failed along the way everything in
your iPhone kind of happened right so
internet GPS touchscreen even Siri in
some ways traces its initial funding to
that era so what are the problems that
we could actually use to guide fiscal
policy investment policy and industrial
strategy this constant ideological
backlash that that means picking winners
and so at best government should just
kind of redistribute income or just get
the tax policy right and then get the
hell out of the way would not have
gotten us any of the technologies inside
your iPhone
Verena thank you number three and then
there's a couple of younger people down
here Brett number three yeah hi
Maxwell rugby of City of London school
this question isn't directed or isn't
just directed at Mervyn King
but you seem to be an advocate believer
of the cooperation of the global economy
where do countries like the US and China
begin in fixing the situation that
they're in with us Oh in China so much
money okay so have that move in and then
down here yeah what do you think is the
future of the banking system especially
after post briggsie and Trump's America
and now that there is an increasing PE
now there is increasing amount of people
with disposable income there there is
less need to borrow so could that lead
to a bigger recession or crisis or will
the banking system find its ground and
be stable and you also said that there
could be that executives should have a
mission led approach and in theory this
may sound good but in practice this may
not work as well and be as effective
okay so Mervyn china-us and the dynamic
between that and we I didn't quite
understand that
he said no even have been a backer for
the global sort of corporate economy I
was cooperation cooperation so
cooperation so I thought cooperation the
if you look at the world economy today
there are two countries or groups which
have large surpluses China and the
European monetary union that the euro is
the biggest contributor to surpluses
today and there are two countries with
big deficits the US and the UK if you
had those four countries in a room and
said look if we go on like this
we'll have another crisis of some kind
rather than debate endlessly what the
crisis will look like why don't we do
something to stop it happening by trying
gradually to eliminate these surfaces
and deficits there is a basis for a deal
and it takes you four people in one room
to come to an agreement on the timetable
over which they might be able to achieve
it and I think that's worth trying and I
think the IMF should play
roll of behind-the-scenes the person
provided the advice and the help and so
on very briefly on banking I do think we
should put in place some measures an ex
ante framework which everyone buys into
so that we say if there's another crisis
then the central bank will be on hand to
lend money to banks but only because
banks have been made to pay an insurance
premium in advance in all the good years
in order to be entitled to the borrowing
and a crisis so the word bailout would
disappear it would be well the banks
have been paying for this for years and
years now they're entitled to borrow the
political problem comes if you don't
actually charge banks for this and the
good years you can't blame people for
being upset when the banks get a free
ride in the crisis even though when the
crisis comes it's the right thing to do
and since it is the right thing to do
which is to lend money to the banks in a
crisis the right thing to do is not to
pretend that we'll never lend to them
but actually to create a framework that
everyone buys into and this is where the
u.s. is going badly wrong because
Congress is trying to stop the Fed from
lending to banks in a crisis actually
what they need to do is to say we know
they're going to do it so what's the
price the banks will pay in in every
good year what's the how active thought
on the gentleman's question here how
active should government's be this
notion of mission led approach Mariana's
idea that innovation comes from
proactive to state action and well I can
I think is in something without being
without being rude they are active and
the question is just what are they
active in and what are they doing and
where and when they're inactive in
certain areas that's usually an active
choice in of itself I think I only I
mean Marianas talking about getting
innovation going and the role of the
state and encouraging and doing some of
that research of the private sector can
then take up and run with it it's just
stepping back from that to my worry is
more that the British state has become
inactive in the face of a whole host of
structural challenges to who our economy
works for and how we deal with it and
that does not require particularly
complicated economics it does not
require particularly big theories of
how the world works it is required we
have chosen a society not to build any
social housing in large numbers since
the 1980s such as a choice now it's not
cheap it's not easy they were upside
there are downsides but we have made
that decision we can reverse that
tomorrow ok
two final very brief points number two I
think was there sorry yes number two
while we've been speaking tonight the US
stock market has been down more than
five point eight percent in the lowest
for since September 2008 so what's going
on okay BBC doesn't give in there's one
more over this direction was not here
just a quick question for Mervyn Kings
he said after the brexit vote that you
ultimately very strongly critical of the
Treasury forecast and you said they were
really over the top nothing we didn't
actually know what was going to really
happen but kind of more recently that's
kind of quite a topical issue now in the
wake of the criticism of the latest
reverie forecast by Cronin Backstairs so
just wondering what your views on those
latest forecasts were like how that's
kind of getting compared to your
original criticisms in the first place
excellent okay
so let's go through very briefly we were
that is now 8:30 sadly Mariana stock
markets are are they correcting
themselves finally understanding that
they've just been too frothy well today
I read an article in the FT that was
actually saying that the reason they're
flopping is to worry about inflation
from the rise in real wages which just
kind of highlights how messed up things
are so if real wages are finally rising
in the u.s. in theory that would be good
news not bad news and the fact that we
then just look at the stock market as
the sort of thermometer down the throat
of the economy to say the scooters that
bad versus how can we restructure the
economy to be less again driven by
shareholder returns which of course the
stock market is reflecting you know it's
the big question can I just say one
thing about missions yes which is
briefly the point is not government or
not government as I've already said you
know Google's algorithm came from a
government investment Elon Musk five
billion of government investment in to
basically everything he did that's not
the problem that's kind of an old story
the question is what do we want
create do we want a greener economy do
we want a AI how do we get public and
private partnerships that are more
symbiotic a mutualistic and less
parasitic and if we keep going back to
this is it the state is that the market
unfortunately we're not gonna get a new
conversation so especially these
wonderful young people here change the
conversation
Torsten is this the start of the massive
equities correction are we gonna go
because I'm not no idea let's hope not I
mean then obviously the u.s. the US
stock market in particular over the last
year all stock markets around the world
have had with the exception of the UK
had a pretty strong yeah so 6% is only
undoing an element of that they'll be
slightly surprised if it's still 6% by
tomorrow night but we shall find out a
Mervin quick line on the stock markets
but I think more people in here may be
more interested in your views of
forecasts and conditional analyses if
we're going to be more precise about the
recent Treasury paper on that issue but
any stock markets and then our forecasts
rubbish if we were on the BBC camera
your producer would have cut you off two
minutes you would have actually and I
thought I should be brief one as I said
earlier this evening when interest rates
start to rise asset prices will fall
back relative to incomes well that was a
pretty good prediction because they
obviously have been rising falling back
relatively we need your wall three well
obviously someone was tweeting to Wall
Street one of the problems in the
referendum campaign was that and to many
economists fell into this trap in my
view they pretended that they actually
could put forward precise quantitative
figures and have credibility economists
are very good at framing arguments so
the arguments that economists framed
about the possible consequences of
briggsie that would have been a useful
contribution but when people said every
family will be 4,300 pounds worse off
that was very foolish because any non
economist would say I don't understand
the economics of this but I'm absolutely
sure that they cannot post
we know that everyone's going to be
4,300 pounds worse off and they're
trying to con me and I'm afraid that was
a rational response to the claims and I
think this use of precise figures is is
dangerous and if you go too far down
that road you end up making the numbers
up so I think we should be pretty
cautious about precise figures and
numbers thank you so much it is 833
thank you so much for your patience
thank you to total squared thank you for
turning Marvin and Mariana thank you for
coming